So going back to our choices for
reducing the AMAT, we have seen
that we can reduce the hit time.
We have now seen that there are
techniques that reduce the miss rate.
And the final set of techniques
are those that reduce the miss penalty.
So when we miss,
we don't suffer as much as before.
So the first technique for
using the missed penalty is
to overlap multiple misses.
If time goes in this direction,
our processor does a lot of activity
multiple instructions per cycle.
And at some point it does a load for
example.
And now that load tries
to be found in the cache.
And if not, we're going to go to
memory and it eventually comes back.
Now if you have a fancy
out of order processor,
it doesn't stop here and wait.
What it does is it finds
other instructions to do.
So even after we start
fetching the data from memory,
the processor is continuing.
But eventually it starts
running out of things to do.
And probably before the load
comes back from memory,
the processor runs out of resources.
Remember that it cannot
commit this load.
So eventually for example,
it will fill up the ROB or
maybe even sooner than that it will
run out of reservation stations,
if a lot of things depend on this load.
So some part of this missed latency
is going to be directly added to
the execution time, but
some part of it is actually overlapping
with the processor activity.
During the time, between,
trying to execute this load,
and running out of things to do,
this processor might actually issue
another load that will be a cache miss.
So, if we have what is
called a blocking cache,
then this load cannot be done until
the first load is finished and
only at this point this load can
really be tried in the cache.
We realize it's a miss,
we suffer the miss latency, and
meanwhile because the processor can
commit these instructions here,
the processor can overlap some of this
miss latency with some other activity.
We can also have a non-blocking
cache and a non-blocking cache can
support things like hit under a miss,
meaning while
we are having a cache miss, hits to
other blocks in the cache that are sent
by the processor will be serviced and
returned to the processor with data.
And also we can have what is called
a miss under a miss, in which case
while we are having a miss,
we can send another request to memory.
So let's look at what that looks like.
So our processor is
happily chugging along,
it has this first load
that suffers a miss.
We check in the cache, we wait for
it to come back from memory,
we continue working,
and eventually run out of things to do
because they depend on this first load.
But the idea is that now this load here
that also suffers a miss will have
its own check in the cache and
when we realize it's a miss
we will send it to memory.
So it will come back here.
Now what we have is when the first
load comes back from memory,
there is a burst of activity.
It starts drying out because we
are still waiting for the second load.
But then the second load comes back and
we are very quickly back
to a normal operation.
So now, as you can see, the inactivity
in the processor used to be this and
this and now it's just this and
maybe a small amount here.
So by overlapping the miss
time of the two loads,
we have almost cut
the penalty to on performance
to half of what it was because
before we had to wait twice this.
Now we really wait once and
maybe some little more.
If we manage to find three or
four rows that overlap.
Then a blocking cacher will pay
the penalty three or four times.
Here we might be paying one
penalty plus a little bit more.
The property that the processor
is exploiting here is called
memory level parallelism.
Here, the memory never gets
more than one access at a time.
Here, the memory gets accesses
to process them in parallel.
So, of course,
our memory needs to be able to do this.
But if it can't, then a non-blocking
cache that can do miss under miss,
can dramatically cut down
on the cost of misses,
instead of seeing the full miss latency
being added to the memory access time.
We are really seeing that the penalties
of the two misses overlap.
So really we paid a penalty once and
we get 1, 2, 15 misses in exchange.